[Music]
there's a lot of talk about uh
disappointments and things we haven't
gotten done
we're gonna get a lot of them done i
might add
president biden trying to make the best
of a week of epic failure and
embarrassment
the white house now reeling after
suffering one humiliating blow after
another the supreme court slapping down
biden's vax mandate inflation surging to
the highest level in 40 years while
biden's poll numbers are plummeting to
record lows and it gets worse biden
getting called out by some in his own
party for his unhinged voting rights
speech in atlanta that stacey abrams
snubbed
democrat senator kirsten cinema crushing
his plan to kill the filibuster before
it even got started
as far as the pandemic that joe biden
promised to shut down cases are hitting
record highs
and that's just a small taste of the
major setbacks press secretary jensachi
spinning like she's never spun before to
try to clean up the mess biden's left
behind
promised to bring decades of dc
experience to the oval office but build
back better has not passed voting rights
apparently not going to pass and vaccine
requirements that he likes are
apparently illegal what happened look
back at last year and what we were able
to accomplish that include getting the
american rescue plan passed he also
pressed despite skeptics to get a
bipartisan infrastructure bill passed
the work of an administration continues
after one year what happened to the guy
who when he was elected said to make
progress we must stop treating our
opponents as our enemy he was not
comparing them as humans he was
comparing the choice
and the media that's tried to prop up
and champion biden every step of the way
is now melting down over this week of
incompetence listen
president joe biden has had a very tough
week i know they're never supposed to
look at the poll numbers but my goodness
every time i think the white house
thought they've hit bottom there seems
to be a new bottom it is hard to think
of them as anything other than
right-wing ideologues they should all
just have right-wing talk radio shows
they are not justices in the great
tradition of supreme court justices
they're just politicians occasional
cinema did something that is
extraordinary she
completely embarrassed politically
embarrassed the leader of her own party
and the sitting president of the united
states
and you know things have hit rock bottom
when the clintons are getting involved
bill and hillary are swooping in and now
giving joe biden advice
on what to do next dagan if the clintons
come and offer you advice
i think it's a good idea to just maybe
be careful hillary clinton wants joe
biden's job yeah if he is if he takes
advice from her
he is as dumb as we think he is here's
my headline a loss for biden is a win
for america think about this so some of
these setbacks this week will actually
be great for the country and the economy
and maybe even by extension bynum
company in the white house the supreme
court knocking down the vaccine mandate
will it will help companies keep and
hire workers it will prevent the supply
chain problems from getting worse and
prop up the economy again it's they
wanted to throw wrenches into the works
of our fine economic system that's not
going to happen the buildback better
monstrosity is dead
five trillion dollar welfare program
it's that would have made inflation
worse so that helps the federal reserve
fight inflation and then keeping the
filibuster intact means that the nation
is
stays the course it's not it's good for
the country it's not far left or far
right but how bad is it for joe biden
today a group of senate democrats
including joe manchin and kirsten sinema
sent a letter to the white house wanting
and i'm going to paraphrase here wanting
to know what the hell is going on with
the coveted response it was written by
senator jackie rosen but also
john also ossoff and mark kelly signed
it i think it's the third letter from
congressional democrats this week that
two trillion dollar plan that jinsaki
was bragging about less than one percent
of it was for therapeutics to treat
covet instead these people in the white
house have been jawboned about masking
vaccines
and testing
and all three of those have been a
failure yeah brian the new testing plan
they're gonna have a website live on
wednesday we'll be monitoring that and
then
it's going to take up to maybe 12 days
to ship the tests once you order it 12
days what are they the carrier pigeon
how are they getting them to the right
know what number what about ordering
something today i know you have a big
weekend coming up and you like to go
home to delaware can someone fill out an
invoice in that department and just
order the test we're not asking to
innovate the test not ask to even
innovate the therapeutics not asking to
innovate the vaccines we're asking to
execute execute because you said that
you guys had all the experience you know
how to do this you were four years prior
you had it for eight years this is
basically the same group you got susan
rice you got ron clayne who was helping
the vice president last time they've
been friends for years you got to fire
everybody you got a clean house this is
a flat-out disaster and so i always say
to myself
what is for a democrat where do you go
from here so i'm thinking to myself see
if you can get some wins the
infrastructure deal was a win when they
both agree on electoral college uh
decided it's a problem with the vice
president whether it's joe biden or it's
mike pence or it's al gore when they
have to go gavel in the official tally
it seems to be an issue there seems to
be blow-ups every time so let's just
forget about that we both sides agree on
that take that and then i look down and
i say what did he talk about today
he talked about doing police reform
what
police reform we have these cities
overrun with crime in two blocks we're
going to be talking about carjacking 101
and now he's talking about police reform
you're going to crack down on cops if
there's anything that should be left on
us on the side it's that and if i i
don't want to take harold ford's talking
points but but you got to look for a
thing you can get some wins on so talk
to joe manchin now and bill clinton had
great advice by the way talk to manchin
find out what he wants how do you build
back better and pass it and the rest of
the stuff run on it so you run on it
next time you want four more years and
you go ahead and say i got some of bill
back better and instead of vilifying
these moderates include them in and say
this is the best i can do and lastly the
worst thing to happen to joe biden i
think historians will write is for him
to invite those historians to the white
house to talk about fdr and lbj and for
him to win those two senate seats in
georgia it gave him the sense that he
could do anything even though you think
he knows reality he can't do anything
well i was going to go to sandra next
but you just name checked harold ford jr
so harold ford jr
how bad is it is it bad or is it really
bad
so i think brian's frame is the right
one um
you've gotta if you're in that white
house now and again had a lot of good
points i i would disagree with some of
them but i think the overall thrust is
that it's not going well so you got to
reset your whole frame when you're
president
you have two jobs your first is your
commander in chief so you think about
the geopolitical threats china russia
north korea iran the challenges we face
in our own hemisphere obviously with the
border and obviously in the middle east
and then you think about the domestic
challenges and we've had a few really
emerge covet obviously the president won
because of it crime again our border and
supply chains the pressure it's creating
on inflation are in our economy if i'm
him i sit back and say what is it to
brian's point how do we create within
these thin majorities we have in the
house and senate an agenda that's going
to begin to address these concerns frame
those concerns and frame them
consistently and i would argue
constantly we've had this conversation
around the table before and we all have
very strong opinions about it but i root
for whoever the president is we want
kova defeated we want inflation tame we
want our geopolitical adversaries to
know that they can't push us around so
the president's got to reset reframe and
if that means bringing new personnel
around he should consider that i'm not
sure that's what he has to do but if he
does he should consider it but he's got
to get a frame a set and a reset and go
out and meet people where they are the
american people and again grab those
wins that are easy wins in front of you
because one victory can produce another
victory and another victory after that
will sandra answer harold ford jr's
question does he need to fire anybody
um i don't know if he'll have to i mean
can you imagine jen sachi want to stick
around much longer after this she's got
a tough gig i mean i woke up flipping
the channels hearing uh
cnn saying biden had a week from hell
john king the country's frustrated the
headline on axios was biden's epic
failures in usa today writing that biden
just had a terrible horrible no-good
very bad day and it's going to get worse
i mean
jesse when you were going down the list
of all these failures just this week
alone i checked them off so that i could
i could go where you left off
and you left out inflation hitting its
highest level since 1982 mcconnell
taking to the senate floor to go after
that speech he gave in georgia on
tuesday where he was stubbed but snubbed
by stacy abrams and he finished the week
thursday with that lunch on capitol hill
coming out and to the microphone
acknowledging that his voting
legislation is unlikely to pass i mean
it really couldn't have gotten worse and
i'll just leave off on this
jen saki announced this morning that
he's going to hold a formal press
briefing on wednesday press conference i
should say on wednesday the eve of the
first year in office for this presidency
that's thursday that marks one year
what are they going to say how do they
spin this
and it's tough to really even guess what
victories they're going to be able to
tout on wednesday
it's been a rough week it's been a rough
year
they better do a little bit of a
they better do a little bit of
looking back to see where they can
correct because hillary clinton sees an
opportunity oh
crooked is circling
the worst possible thing to have
happened hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else